[Música]
y en directo américa llegó el momento de
hablar de economía por ello le dé la
bienvenida a mi compañero luís méndez
louis empezamos hablando de rusia porque
representante del gobierno de vladímir
putin se muestran optimistas respecto a
lo que será la tasa de crecimiento para
el presente año así es andrés hay que
recordar que esta nación debido a las
consecuencias de la guerra va a
presentar una contracción para este año
2022 pero de acuerdo con el
viceprimerministro android bolso para la
contracción en la economía rusa como
consecuencia de la invasión a ucrania
podría estar por debajo de un 3 por
ciento la cifra se muestra como un
resultado optimista en medio de lo que
ha sido el impacto de la guerra
recordemos que al inicio de la operación
militar que inició el pasado 24 de
febrero y la posterior implementación de
sanciones por parte de occidente de
economía rusia sufrió en parte por las
caídas de los mercados y también por la
depreciación del rublo la moneda de
curso oficial en ese país de acuerdo con
el representante de vladimir putin la
economía presentaría una caída que
estaría por debajo del 3% y fue más
específico indicó
levemente por encima del
2% pero recordemos que los organismos
gubernamentales han ido disminuyendo la
contracción para el presente año el
banco central por ejemplo en abril
pronóstico una caída entre un 8 y un 10
por ciento pero en mayo el ministerio de
economía estimó la caída en 78 % en
agosto este mismo organismo revisó ese
dato a la baja a menos 42 por ciento y
el actual cifra otorgada por el
viceprimerministro durante un encuentro
con los medios de comunicación
boat shop informó que la demanda interna
en el país había mostrado signos de
reactivación no obstante la publicación
qatarí al yazira en un reportaje refiere
que los ciudadanos están disminuyendo su
capacidad de compra en medio de la alta
inflación que las autoridades estiman
que estaría por el orden de por encima
del 12% mientras tanto el escrito
sostiene que si bien el impacto de las
sanciones se está afectando a los
ciudadanos éstos se muestran optimistas
porque confían en que rusia podrá
producir los bienes que él actuales
momentos son importados y no están
llegando al país como consecuencia de
las sanciones pues hablamos ahora de la
energía porque los precios siguen
disparados en europa y es que la
reducción del suministro de gas por
parte de rusia hacia algunos países
europeos ha generado esta situación por
otro lado funcionarios de la unión
europea como el caso de la ministra de
energía de bélgica advierten que de no
encontrarse una solución pronta estarían
afrontando inviernos terribles para los
próximos 5 a 10 años diversos líderes de
la unión europea siguen buscando
alternativas para disminuir los elevados
precios de la energía durante un
encuentro con el canciller alemán con
las jons el primer ministro checo peter
fiala informó sobre la necesidad de
meter los precios dentro de la
arquitectura de la energía por su parte
úrsula von der leyen informó que el
bloque sigue considerando medidas
urgentes para controlar el aumento de
precios por otro lado también busca
romper el vínculo entre el gas y el
costo de la energía sobre esto hay que
señalar que el 29 de agosto se conoció
que los precios de la energía en
alemania para el año 2023
aaron los mil euros por megavatio/hora y
este martes tendrá un valor de 660 euros
por megavatio/hora es el segundo más
elevado después del de francia con 740
euros por megavatio/hora hasta el año
pasado en la unión europea importaba un
40% del gas que consume de rusia y gran
parte de éste era utilizado para la
generación de energía eléctrica pero
escuchemos que dijo al respecto al
ministro de economía alemán
mike hart es la consecuencia de una
dependencia inusual del gas ruso barato
que alemánia conscientemente ha
construido y también se construyó en
este ministerio ahora falta y no va a
volver estamos pagando literalmente un
alto precio
en medio de toda esta situación el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr sales que
ofreció apoyar a europa con el tema de
la energía
x ha tomado el tren generamos mucha
energía nuclear a pesar de la guerra
podemos conectarnos en las redes
europeas estamos listos para
proporcionar a europa electricidad
barata
louis y ahora pasamos a brasil porque en
medio de la campaña electoral el
candidato luis ignacio luna da silva
anunció sus planes para la amazonía así
es andrés y es que el ex presidente ha
mostrado su deseo de explotar de forma
sostenible
esta vasta extensión del territorio
brasileño con el conjunto la sociedad de
la unión europea el anuncio fue
realizado durante una reunión en la que
estuvo presente una comisión de
eurodiputados socialistas el anuncio se
opone a los planes del actual presidente
ya y revolucionario quien ha manifestado
su deseo de explotar el territorio para
extraer sus riquezas la zona es rica en
madera minerales y cuenta con un
importante potencial agrario lula ha
señalado que de ganar las elecciones
brasil es decir tus socios como la
europea bien sea a través de inversiones
alianzas o intercambio de experiencias
louis muchas gracias por la información
económica seguimos con más aquí en
directo américa